foreign
[Music]
welcome to a new episode of architecting
with Google Cloud
given that we all use a mobile device we
are familiar with the concept of a lock
screen and the content that can be
served on it but what if I tell you that
220 plus million active users engage
with a specific lock screen service
4 out of five android devices in India
have a lock screen that is personalized
live available in your local language
and more
we are pleased to bring you this episode
to talk about Lance and I'm thrilled to
welcome Arun prakash from glance to show
and tell us more about their exciting
Journey welcome to the show Arun can you
tell us a bit more about your background
and what you are doing at glance
and part of a central team which takes
care of Technology research and
Technology acceleration of adoption in
glands we are also responsible for cloud
infrastructure maintaining and Cloud
solution glance itself is a consumer
internet company that provides
interactive lock screen experience to
the end users including personalized
content hyper life shows and new gaming
experiences and where you can go and
watch live tournaments as well thanks
everyone for sharing the details now
going back to the lock screen given that
it's something that's available on
phones and you know there have been
multiple attempts to create a unique
experience around it
so what I'm curious about is to learn
how glance went about addressing the
lock screen what is unique about your
experience and how has it evolved over
the years with different consumer
preferences
was to give Dynamic wallpapers according
to the user's preference and over the
time it evolved into something like a
smart internet slash media consuming
platform
and we have a lot of integration
directly with our OEM partners and in
India and Indonesia especily and that
uniquely positions glance as the only
and highest scale player in India
in-house we have news products and
gaming and live consuming products
making them seamlessly available on the
user lock screen itself
excellent so given that it's not just
any lock screen experience that we are
talking about here you said it's
personalized it's available in a
language of choice it has live
experiences plus you are doing all of
this at scale so how did you go about
achieving that at glance the last screen
feed is the main use case and
serving fresh content to the last screen
is of utmost important so glands has the
400 million plus devices in in Silver
Base so glance as a system needs to be
highly reactive and highly scalable so
to be scalable and to also Thrive for
user relevant experience and and all our
backend systems are containerized and
deployed on kubernetes clusters so we
have active passive kubernetes cluster
just to make sure that we are almost all
the time available and kubernetes itself
takes care of our application scaling as
well as infrastructure scaling and we
have a lot of in-memory caches and few
distributed caches and few distributed
DBS to make sure our latencies are in
some
subsequence submill like few of them are
even sub milliseconds and micro Services
architecture is used to democratize
different business units to individually
operate build out features and deploy to
yourself and we have near real time as
well as real time personalization engine
to give user per request most eligible
contents
okay now that we know how customers use
glance's solution and you talked about
how you are achieving some of the scale
let's Deep dive into the user's Journey
so could you give us an overview of the
architecture what goes on behind the
scenes to achieve this experience
specifically you know I'd like you to
break this up into multiple Parts one is
how the content is created
then maybe we can start looking at how
the content is served to the users on
their lock screens and what makes the
whole personalized experience possible
let's start with the control creation
flow so there are Publishers who are
creating the content in a CMS portal
that we are powered and that CMS portal
takes care of separating the metadata
and pushing it into a cloud SQL DB at
the same time separating the assets and
pushing it into blob stores and now as
the content is available next we have to
deliver those content to the users so it
starts from user asking for content and
that fetch request comes to our load
balancer which also acts as a router
delivers that request to a Content
server and to decide what content tools
are we need a bit of enrichment of the
user device so that comes from a user
State system where we are storing the
user States in a standard DB and it is
first and interest and that request is
then forwarded to micro Services which
we talked about where different business
units have their own business logic so
each of the business units has the
responsibility to send most relevant
content to the user so now the business
units the micro Services actually goes
and fetches the content from this Cloud
SQL DB and it is all the time available
in in memory so it not actually fetching
the content directly every time and then
it does personalization with the help of
the text CIA to figure out okay what is
the most eligible contents topics
ranking contents for each of the
business units and that contents are
again sent back to the content server
which is transformed it to something
that is readable by the SDK file and
once the content is delivered now the
user starts experiencing the contents
interacting with the contents so those
telemetries are captured on the device
side and it is sent as another request
to the same load balancer now load
balancer routes it to a Telemetry server
which is a even server which just logs
all the events as it is into Kafka now
this Kafka
events are available as streaming events
as well as it has connectors to deploy
it in Block stores now these events from
blob stores are consumed by vertex a as
well as some of the events directly
consumed from Kafka by the taxi to
Define okay what is the personalization
that's happening for the next fetch so
that is happening as well and both batch
time and real time and we have 15 15
minutes once Bachelor process is running
to make sure we are updating our models
and every 15 minutes so that's how the
entire system is working
thanks Arun for taking us through the
architecture now given that there were
so many technology decisions that you
are to make and you have to evolve this
solution I'm sure the journey had its
ups and downs so could you highlight for
us a few challenges that you might have
faced as you went and achieved this
scale is one of the initial problems
that Lance has faced so as I said like
there are so many devices so many
content with stickers coming together
and how are you going to scale for those
requests so initially it was just a VM
based jar deployment that was happening
and we had to over provision just to
make sure we are delivering content we
are not dropping requests so then we had
to migrate it to containerized and then
container instances and then we have
started deploying them in kubernetes
servers so that the kubernetes itself
takes care of the scaling part and the
infra cost is also optimized for us and
the other major
issue was to experience
user side of events on the server side
so basically users has experienced our
there is our content sorry and once the
content experience is done we need to
know like how it has been done on the
client side so the telemetries are
captured on the device side and sent to
us and initially it was just counters
and booleans just to know like okay
whether the content is delivered whether
it was rendered those kind of things now
it has been a full-fledged pipeline
where we are getting real-time events
real-time analysis happening and there
are hardly daily rollups happening and
there are custom dashboards for each of
the features and business units so
directly product or business can go and
verify their dashboards and
after a major outage to bring plants
back up so we have faced those outages
couple of times in the past so where the
availability Zone has gone down our
cluster has gone down where we are not
able to reach our systems so at that
time to bring up itself it's like
entirely manual process you have to go
and reposition everything all those
things but now we have all our
and we just
it's an aircraft how much time it takes
to provision those services and VMS on
the background for the cloud so
everything is automated and we have a
lot of storage backups data backups to
make sure okay things are coming back
online as soon as we have the
Zone only that's how it is right now and
we have behavioral based modeling on our
side because there is no use of profile
directly available so everything is
based on behavioral patterns of users so
to have 400 million plus devices in real
time
personalization so we had to have our
own scale issues to face that and now we
have both real-time and near real-time
personalization running smoothly on the
cloud and application monitoring was
also issued previously where how do you
monitor whether it was through logs or
whether it was through metrics how it is
going to happen I was going to appear
for the developers so now we have a
proper integrated system with lot of
Prometheus Victoria Matrix based
toolings to power our grafana dashboards
interesting to see the different
challenges that you had and how you
solved it so looking at some of the
challenges which you mentioned around
you know scale around personalization
around containerization so any specific
Google cloud services that have helped
you uh you know to achieve some of the
points which you mentioned few major
offerings that we have accepted from
Google is basically gke scanner and
vertex a so these are the like most
useful tools for us to make sure that
our content delivery and the
personalization is up to real time so we
have gke as a seamless and up-to-date
characters cluster and current is
cluster I mean and it is maintained by
Google Cloud itself so all our
deployments config management everything
is happening through kubernetes itself
and spanner in the form of distributed
DB we are storing more than 400 million
device States and a different like
behavioral patterns and different user
cohorting all those things are happening
on spanner so it's like scaling up to
tens of thousands of writes and reads
and since it is a distributed store we
are getting like few millisecond latency
to get those data and vertex a itself is
entirely a bigger infrastructure for the
serving so because it's doing both near
real time and real-time personalization
for us and we are recently onboarded on
live streaming apis where we are giving
the user live stream experience through
gcp live streaming solution and we have
onboarded on gcps record program which
helps us understand how they have
architected their Solutions so that it
helps us onboarding much easier
and the major component for a cloud
company is basically to understand their
Cloud costing so cost monitoring as a
tool it is directly available from gcp
in the form of bigquery and GK usage
metering so we get application Level
ownership of whatever cost that is going
to be coming in the bill thanks Arun for
sharing how we are using Google cloud
services I'm just curious what we can
expect from glance going forward Going
Global is the next major discussion so
we have already in presence in India
Indonesia Colombia Mexico and Brazil and
as you speak we are making inroads into
us and Japan and then we are it to
partner with three of the other oems and
that is the next and that's going to add
to our scale and
understanding Global consumption of the
content and how users behave is an
overwhelming process so that's going to
be a continuous evolution of changes in
the gland systems and some of the gaming
and live streaming Solutions will have
deep integration in gcp itself to
provide to the user needs thanks Arun
for joining our show where can viewers
go and learn more about Clans we have
our company website glance.com where you
can go and figure out like how our
company operates and then there is a
glance screen LinkedIn page where you
can go and see what is happening in the
company what are the achievements that
are happening in the company what are
the shout outs all those things and
there is a medium blog that is our Tech
blog where we keep our engineering
researchers and whatever recently
engineering missions that we have made
and what research base have it has
happened and it is pretty up to date you
can go and check great that brings us to
the end of this episode where we saw how
glance is bringing personalized and live
content to the lock screen of your
device
if you like the content please share and
subscribe to our Channel where we
continue to bring you awesome Tech
stories thank you Arun for joining us on
this show thanks Roman thanks for having
me here thanks everyone till the next
episode thanks for watching
[Music]